excusez moi se passe bien de fortes
chances que vous devenu numéro deux ans
que j'attends sa place de numéro deux à
la fois
voir ma meilleure amie ça fait deux ans
qu est parti du québec
tu es ce que tu étais québécois attend
encore une fois le mot québec
je vous vire tout ce qu'est ce que c'est
que cette grosse ringarde à l'accueil
surprise chez moi chez moi et tu
resteras attaque était le top 10 a accès
les victoires depuis la meilleure amie
dont très bizarre comment tu me parles
d'une essence
c'est là secret je découvrirai qui
meurent on raisonne martyrs kalistick
ouest extérieurs ont été toutes ces
histoires là les québécois tout ça il
est venu au tabac café merci très propre
avec des quoi je suis sur le coup l'un
n'a pas de cellule terroriste et on
n'aura jamais se dote de ton implication
et rit on peut pas être amoureux est et
reste à la fin je me faire tomber moi
secret
on va faire bander les foules
audrey pour pêcher alors faites vous
après quoi vous êtes viré
officier
ce congrès
avant tout de bons jeux fera
waouh
à
juste que tu m'aides a décroché seule
passe
la confiance jusqu'au bout
m